it's clearly a pretty obvious thing to
stick a bit of filling between two
slices of something along the lines of
bread and eat it with your hands
but the British sandwich industry is
worth eight billion pounds a year across
Western Europe and America sandwiches
are booming some are made in home but
most bought on them run it's been done
for thousands of years whether it's with
flatbread or yeasted loaves cheese or
meat especially by those eating away
from a table for instance working on the
fields or as a casual snack it wasn't
named though or even recognized as a
thing which needed a name until the 18th
century the story goes that John Montagu
the 4th Earl of Sandwich a town on the
south coast of England was at a gambling
table one night decided not to stop for
supper and ordered a simple snack of
beef between two slices of bread the
real story is a bit less clear-cut
Montagu wasn't a big spender he was
broke most of the time and his idea
didn't come out of nowhere he'd almost
certainly seen pitted breads used with a
filling on his travels in the eastern
Mediterranean whatever the truth the
concept was certainly named after him
and the word was in fashionable use by
the 1770s early sandwich has stayed
close to the original idea they were
designed for quick eating initially by
men doing business at coffee houses or
playing cards and then for more mixed
tea parties ball buffets and light
suppers early 19th century sandwiches
were intended to be elegant often served
on doilies with the crusts cut off but
the name was also used for the age-old
workers meal the thick bread butter and
a universal filling of ham and by the
middle of the Victorian period sandwich
sellers clustered around every factory
gate one writer called them mouth
distorted and pleaded for sandwich
makers to make them delicate and
delicious his suggested fillings
included bone marrow in nasturtiums
potted Woodcock sliced sweetbreads sea
kale and oranges soaked in brandy a more
humble alternative was provided by
best-selling author Isabella Beaton she
suggested a toast sandwich literally a
slice of cold toast between two slices
of bread well seasoned with salt and
pepper it was apparently particularly
well-suited for invalids in the 20th
century the British sandwich of two
slices of bread and a filling was joined
by other alternatives from overseas the
Scandinavian open sandwich was praised
by British food writer Marguerite
pattern in the 90
sixties while filled Pitters croissants
and wraps have also crept in to join the
basic bread and butter version toasted
sandwiches came out of the states in the
1920s when the toasty maker was patented
the US had become sandwich Central even
briefly having a national sandwich day
on November the 3rd the original Earl of
Sandwich his birthday but it wasn't
until 1980 that the pre-packed sandwich
made its first appearance in Marks &
Spencer and initially only in five
stores they were an instant hit and now
the working lunch is almost synonymous
with a prawn cocktail sandwich still M&S
is biggest seller the science behind
constructing a non soggy sandwich which
can last all day is very big business
indeed of course the predictable
fillings still vie with slightly more
avant-garde attempts the Sanya which
anyone and many sandwich aficionados
we're blind that the biggest improvement
to any bought sandwich is a layer of
ready salted crisps
you